one of the police officers involved in a
controversial traffic stop of a black
and latino army officer in december
has been fired body camera footage shows
windsor virginia police officers joe
gutierrez and danielle crocker
pointing their guns at army second
lieutenant coron nazario before
gutierrez pepper sprays him lieutenant
nazario was released without being
charged and he
is now suing both officers cbs news
correspondent christina raffini has the
story
what's going on how many occupants are
in your vehicle
it's only myself why are your weapons
drawn what's going on
the door slowly step out get out get out
the car
get out now i have not committed any
crime in body camera
and cell phone video army's second
lieutenant caron nozzario
still in his uniform holds his hands out
the window of his new car
while two windsor virginia police
officers guns drawn
order him to get out i'm honestly afraid
to get out can i yeah
you should be get out of the car now get
out of the car get your hands off me
please
get your hands off me you know what get
your hands off me get your hands off me
i didn't do anything don't do that
nazario repeatedly asks
why he's been pulled over before
ex-officer joe gutierrez pepper sprays
him through the open window
sir just get out the car i'm trying to
breathe my dog is in the back
my dog is choking right get out of the
car nozario is then kicked
forced to the ground and put in
handcuffs why
am i being treated like this the
incident report
says nozario was pulled over for not
having tags displayed on his suv
but the temporary dealer plate is
visible in the officer's body cam video
the report also said officers treated it
as a high risk stop
because nozario had tinted windows and
drove at a
very low speed to a gas station before
pulling over
a move gutierrez later said he
understood
as far as you not stopping because you
weren't comfortable and you wanted a
wellness spot
which happens he did everything that we
are told to do to
for everyone's safe attorney jonathan
arthur represents cesario
when you look in your rear view mirror
and you see two firearms trained at you
you've got to get real calm real quick
if you want to get out of there a lot
you know it's a credit to his training
what are you a specialist corp what are
you
i'm a lieutenant according to the
lawsuit the officers also threatened to
derail nazario's military career if he
pursued further action
against them if you want to just chill
let this go
and no charges filed we'll take the
handcuffs off get your bottle of water
to drink on and sit here until you feel
comfortable driving
now after that search of his vehicle
turned up no violations nozario was
released without charge
the governor of virginia has asked state
police to investigate the incident cbs
news reached out to the windsor police
department we did not hear back
anthony nozario's attorney said he
wanted to file the lawsuit to hold these
two officers accountable
and so these kinds of stops stop
happening christina raffini thanks
christina
wow i mean i can't imagine pulling into
a gas station and suddenly facing a
couple of guys with guns look pointed in
your window but this is the thing guys
he was calm the whole time
he was calm they weren't he's in uniform
and when they said he drove at a low
rate of speed that should show he wasn't
trying to get away
and i don't blame him as a black man in
this country stop getting stopped on a
rural highway he's thinking
let me get to where there's light where
it's lit and he immediately started
cooperating just
this is the thing that bothers me it was
such an issue of power and control they
did not treat that man like a human
being yeah
and that's what's so troubling about it
and since when do you get pulled over
for having tinted windows
yeah they could have solved that much
differently driving slow was a problem
we know driving fast is a problem so
what's the solution here
they said he got he got pulled over to
anthony because he didn't have a
license plate on the back it wasn't
there but it was out it was it was a
temporary one
in the window a report showed it was
yeah it was there take a peek